foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Piers Morgan I'm censored tonight
artificial intelligence is either going
to transform Humanity or completely
destroy it so should we be very excited
or very afraid is it going to take your
job will it take my job should we try to
stop it or is it already too late to try
we've got some big questions and some
big brains with hopefully some big
answers
[Music]
from the news building in London this is
Piers Morgan uncensored well good
evening London welcome to Piers Morgan
unsensitive we're on the brink of one of
the biggest turning points in human
history society and Life as we know it
could be about to change beyond all
recognition and according to people like
Elon Musk one of the richest and
smartest people alive well the future's
here
if you say like over
20 30 year time frame
um I think things will be transformed
beyond belief
what you probably think you probably
won't recognize Society in 30 years
um
like I do think we're fairly close you
asked me about artificial general
intelligence I think we're perhaps only
three years maybe six years away from it
does this this decade
wow that was Elon Musk last night
artificial intelligence could upend Our
Lives as dramatically as the Industrial
Revolution the invention of the internet
or it could end our lives it's that big
mind reading AI is just a lot of
paralyzed 40 year old man to walk again
by creating a wireless digital link
between his spinal cord and his brain
that is clearly a brilliant benefit of
AI chat Bots write in perfect human
prose by scaring the entire internet in
fractions of a second they can pass
exams write literature and code software
in an instant AI can generate music
photography corporate logos aren't based
on any instructions no matter how Off
the Wall ask AI to create a painting of
a fox balancing an apple on his foot in
the style of Salvador Dali and it'll
give you this
takes three seconds it's free and
anybody can use it and the more people
who do use it or the smarter it gets
that how it is how it works but you may
have already spotted the slight problem
humans created this technology beyond
that it doesn't really need us and even
in its nice and form it can generate
very convincing fakes the Florida
governor Ron DeSantis launched his U.S
presidential campaign on Twitter spaces
last night with Elon Musk an audio only
chat room on the app it had a few Tech
issues so Donald Trump is Big rival for
the Republican nomination posted this I
have to admit very realistic and and
clever satire in response
hi everyone Welcome to our Ron DeSantis
Twitter space Hello is my microphone
working correctly George can you just
wait while we no can you hear me we can
all hear you George can you just hold on
for a second I
don't hear you fine
I think George knows how to use Twitter
hello can you hear me now can I please
make my big announcement now everyone
just hello just shut up George can
somebody just mute George
dick could you try not to cough on them
okay so how are we going to take out
Trump you guys uh
uh guys from the FBI this is not a
private call this is a public Twitter
space everyone can listen in
that's all fake I didn't actually happen
obviously but it's a brilliant fake it's
very convincing I watched it the first
time and thought is that what happened
last night now imagine that's a fairly
trivial thing but imagine if it was
footage from a wall for example a lot of
people can now create a lot of problems
with very little effort thanks to AI
these photographs of trump being
arrested were entirely fake and
generated by artificial intelligence
this AI generated hoax photograph of an
explosion as the Pentagon sparked a
stock market Panic recently if we can't
believe our own eyes and ears well how
will democracy function and if AI can do
so many of our jobs well what the hell
are we gonna do
British prime minister Rishi sunak has
now acknowledged that AI could be an
existential threat more than a thousand
of the smartest people in the world are
so worried about it they've called for a
complete six-month Hiatus on its
development depending on who you ask AI
is about to either save the world or
completely destroy it so tonight we're
going to devote the whole show to try to
work out which is more likely I'm joined
by an esteemed panel of some of the
biggest brains in the AI World Professor
Max tegmark of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology physicist Michio
Kaku author of the new book Quantum
Supremacy Times columnist Matthew said
and editor of the tech website sifted
Amy Lewin well welcome to all of you
um let me start with you Max tank mark
what's going to happen
do you know
it's great to be back
what's going to happen
we shouldn't sit here just like eating
popcorn at the movies waiting to see
what should happen because we are
creating this future right now and it's
the most important job we ever make so
we have to snap out of that passive mode
it's either going to be as you said the
best thing ever to happen to humanity
helping us amplify our own intelligence
to solve all our problems or it's going
to be the end of us and and I think Elon
Musk is right I think
it's not 50 years off it's gonna it's
very likely this decade that
things go to hell in a handbasket or
become great and um
that's why we call for the pause to give
give policy makers a little bit of time
to steer this in in a good direction I'm
confident we can get things right
but we need a little more time to figure
out how to make this safe and make sure
it's something that we control rather
than the other way around
uh Woolly Mammoths used to maraud around
the world dominating all in their wake
there are no woolly mammoths anymore
because humans realize the best way to
deal with them was to get rid of them uh
our robots going to be the
effectively doing that to us what we did
to woolly mammoths
no I don't think so first of all the cat
is out of the bag the point is not to
kill the cat the point is to tame the
cat so that it has the best interests of
humanity at stake realize that in a best
case scenario artificial intelligence
could give us a new golden age a golden
age for society a society of abundance
energy food medicines we're talking
about AI across the board ushering in a
golden age however there are problems
first is jobs we have to retrain workers
so that they can be part of this new
revolution rather than being iced out of
this second of all there are criminals
there are impersonators what happens if
somebody impersonates Vladimir Putin and
declares war on NATO we're in big big
trouble if that happens so it's a cat
that has to be tamed and I think we can
do it because of course we have fact
Checkers and also we have
self-regulation take a look at the movie
industry after every movie there's a
statement saying that this movie was
fake all the actors are fake so there
has to be a disclaimer there has to be a
fact Checker to make sure that the cat
is Tamed
okay
Matthew zahid are you comfortable that
we have the capability
and perhaps the goodness in our hearts
to make AI a positive for the world or
will nefarious forces as they tend to do
with everything
get the cat and turn it wild and
basically trigger the end of mankind
well I'm an instinctive Optimist and I
definitely would bet on the knowledge
and Ingenuity of the human creators of
AI to increase productivity
additional wealth but when you have the
founders some of the pioneers of this
technology talking about an existential
risk let's kind of figure out what that
means it means the 8 billion people
currently alive on the planet can't be a
limit but not just us all of the future
Generations the many billions who could
experience the miracle of consciousness
of existence won't get that opportunity
and what worries me is not knowledge
it's the wisdom even if we decided to
follow the advice of Elon Musk and
impose a moratorium how would it be
enforced what would stop a rogue Nation
well continuing with that development
and then turning on everybody else this
is what economists call a collective
action problem and the only way a
species can solve that is through
cooperation that is precisely the social
quality that human beings are struggling
with not just with AI but with other
existential risks nuclear war climate
change bacteriological development I'm
worried
I'm worried so Amy Lynn are you worried
I think it could go one of two ways I
think this could as some of the people
were saying be amazing for us you know
we could
I think the medical uses you know that
if the companies get together and
they're all competing with each other to
find you know ways to treat breast
cancer exactly that's amazing but as
Matthew said if it goes the other way
and it's being used to create
new weapons of mass destruction not so
good for the world and teacher I mean I
just don't trust the current political
class
to have the breadth of understanding I
got to be honest I don't trust a lot of
people and there's a lot of trust here I
mean let me bring back max I mean you
know what Mitchell was saying uh is
correct I think in in what we'd like to
happen but there's a lot of trust here I
mean the internet for example which is
the kind of the last big thing before AI
the internet remains really woefully
unregulated and pretty dangerous
why would AI not be just a far worse
version of the internet where it all
starts off well-intentioned but actually
it goes to hell quite quickly
trust is the exactly the what the issue
is about we can obviously not trust the
first company that builds artificial
general intelligence to not just become
the most stifling Mega Monopoly ever
right because they can Crush all the
competition with billions of virtual
workers that need no pay except
electricity and they can kill democracy
sort of take everything over you need to
level the playing field we need to I
think instead not reinvent the wheel
here but just learns from our friends in
biotech you know no biotech company will
be allowed to just start selling a new
drug and in the supermarket saying it
cures cancer if it hasn't first
demonstrated that this is safe and we
have Regulators for that in all
countries in the world right so it's
completely absurd that for AI which is
going to have more impact right now is
just the wild west anyone can launch
anything right it's completely legal it
should be on we shouldn't trust
companies should verify we should make
them come and prove that this is safe
and then they can sell it and get really
rich look this is a world that you've
been expert in for a long time you must
also be excited I guess about the
amazing potential of AI what is the one
thing that you're most excited by about
AI
oh I'm incredibly excited about
for example solving
all the problems that have stumped Us in
medicine you know I was in the hospital
not that long ago visiting
a friend who was told she had incurable
cancer and I thought to myself it's not
incurable we haven't been smart enough
to figure out how to cure it that's all
so the sky is the limit as Michio said
we can help life flourish not just for
the next election cycle but for billions
of years and not just on Earth but also
throughout much of our our beautiful
Universe if we get this right and that's
exactly why it's so ridiculous
if we have billions of years of
Awesomeness then we can't even wait six
months so to make sure we get it right
and don't squander that future
you talked about I think it's a good
metaphor for AI the bacteriological
Warfare at the moment the bacterial
logical weapons convention has a global
staff of three people and an annual
budget equivalent to McDonald's takeaway
restaurant that Global regulation is a
complete joke you talk about the
institutions that subscribe to the
jurisdiction the national jurisdictions
but what would be to stop what would
stop a loan fanatic creating a pathogen
with a high infection fatality rate and
a long incubation period at the moment
the regulation is completely Toothless
and also somebody actually you ran the
Oxford AstraZeneca covered vaccine
program said to me I meant the FDA the
Food and Drug Administration that's what
I was talking about where there is a
really well-functioning regulatory
system companies have to prove stuff is
safe before they sell it for those who
subscribe to the jurisdiction of the FDA
but you have one in Britain too I'm sure
we do I mean the question I would put to
you um and maybe I can come to Michio
for this I remember that the boss of the
Oxford AstraZeneca covered vaccine
program telling me uh I had long covered
for a few months he said I wouldn't
worry about long covert if I were you he
said I'd worry about a return of the
plague so I started laughing and he went
no I'm completely serious he said we've
had a massive wake-up call here if we
got a return of the plate with a death
rate of 30 to 40 including children it
would wipe away 34 40 of the planet
um in the wrong hands
AI presumably could create a way for a
nefarious person or entity or state to
create exactly what Matthew said a
pathogen which could cause that kind of
Devastation how do we stop that
happening how do we stop bad people
getting access to the super new
Knowledge from AI to cause devastation
well let me say one thing the key
concept I think is self-regulation the
industry has to regulate itself and the
way that the movie industry the comic
book industry all culture in Western
Society is largely self-regulated and if
it's not then the politicians grandstand
and they try to get elected on the basis
of shutting down some of these media
Outlets so I think we have to let
self-regulation play itself in order to
make sure that the excesses of this
technology don't get out of hand but
also looking at the internet as dung XO
Bing once said of China sometimes you
have to open the window to let the fresh
air in but sometimes a few flies come
through and so yeah the internet has a
few flies but in the main the internet
is a force of democracy it's a force of
Education it has proven its worth to
society imagine a society without the
internet and the same thing with
artificial intelligence I think it has
to be tamed is raw but it has to be
tamed and when it is tamed it'll give us
a new golden age for all of society well
you know what uh Mitchell I really
really really want you to be right
because the alternative is catastrophic
uh Mitchell thank you very much Max
thank you very much indeed you two are
staying with me as we continue through
the Special Edition appears more when I
censored about artificial intelligence
so coming up next millions of jobs
could honestly be affected by AI many
could be lost if they are what happens
to those currently in work you'll be out
of work we'll debate that next
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage stretching it you
can say whatever gender you are for your
sex your male or your female all right
JJ plus he becomes fabulous
but Richie sooner and sets out this
five-point plan what has it achieved so
far nothing when we say believe women
take them at their word I'm sick of
apologies
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back artificial intelligence
could replace the equivalent of 300
million full-time jobs according to
Investment Bank Goldman Sachs and that
transition is already underway BT is
cutting 55 000 jobs with a fifth loss to
AI even Sam additives the former England
Football manager is worried
I've just heard about 40 000 jobs going
from BT
so what they're going to do
you know what I mean so the next piece
of AI comes in another 30 000 job scores
what are they going to do so you know
for me
um it's not a great future
we've got a point isn't it imagine a big
Sam was replaced by a robot or Jurgen
klopp or roboclop as the Daily Star put
in so could our jobs all be at risk or
could AI be used to drive productivity
across the economy joining me now is the
CEO and founder of do not pay the
world's first robot lawyer Joshua
Browder and Jeremy Howard founding
researcher of fast.ai and Matthew said
and Amy Lewin are still with me okay
um Joshua Browder here's my question
about jobs specifically
let's assume for a moment that Ai and
robots take a whole lot of jobs say
Goldman Sachs are right 300 million jobs
all those people are suddenly unemployed
who used to have those jobs
where are the people going to be with
enough income if they're unemployed to
buy the products being made by all the
robots
while uh the the government can give
them money
um I think AI will replace a huge number
of jobs lawyers will be the first to be
replaced by AI because they're charging
hundreds of dollars an hour for copying
and pasting documents but AI will also
create a lot of jobs a lot of jobs today
didn't exist 20 years ago so at my
company do not pay we're now hiring jobs
called prompt engineers and that is
actually telling the AI what to do and
that job didn't even exist a year ago so
I think that will be new and exciting
jobs for people but at the same time
those that charge a lot of money for
doing very little like some lawyers not
all lawyers have to worry about being
replaced you seem very very anti-lawyers
I spend too much time trying to fight
them probably too much money I mean one
thing your chat bought lawyer has
successfully done is overturn almost 200
000 parking tickets I could see you
becoming extremely popular just with
that service alone
yeah for very simple tasks no one has
time to wait on hold for five hours to
save fifty dollars like getting a refund
for a company or getting out of a
parking ticket and so that's the perfect
job for AI saving time and money for
people and um I think those people the
lawyers you see on billboards that
charge a lot of money to do that should
be very worried okay so Jeremy had I
mean look clearly a massive threat to
human employment we're seeing it already
and it's going to move probably faster
and faster but what do we do about this
you can't just have vast ways of the
planet who were employed suddenly not
having employment what do we do
yeah I think we've got to be careful you
know it's not as easy as what Joshua
described there aren't going to be new
jobs to fill in all the old ones and I I
can explain why it's very simple because
think of it this way
we uh we have two things as as humans we
have a body and a brain our body can
move things our brain can think about
things
back in the industrial revolution the
engine was developed and before that in
the UK 80 of people worked on farms and
the engine came along and allowed us to
replace humans using their bodies to
move things with machines and today only
1.5 percent of people work on farms in
the UK that's fine lots of new jobs came
along because we still had something
else to give our brains and so now most
of us do jobs which involved at least to
some extent thinking about things now if
AI can come along and think about things
better than we can
boy are these replacement jobs going to
come from we've got things that can move
stuff we've got things that can think
about stuff so where's the role for
humans I do think there'll be some job
still for example talk show host I think
there are some things where we need a
human you know I don't want to tune into
Piers Morgan bot right
on that that's very interesting you
don't think you do but if I was to have
a a robot AI robot be programmed to look
like me and had access to everything
every question I'd ever asked every
mannerism every Star whatever I reckon
quite quickly they could develop
something which could do a very passable
version of me
right but I still wouldn't tune in like
think of another one are you going to
tune in to the tennis playing Bots like
the fact that you know Roger Federer is
an amazing human is why we like watching
him play tennis so I think like there'll
still be a role of like humans doing
human things and other other people
saying well look at that person that's
amazing so I think there's going to be a
totally different kind of role for
people there won't be jobs in the
classical sense but it could be great
but if we find a way to transition to
this it's not a threat it means you
don't have to go to work and do eight
hours of whatever you're told tomorrow
you can do whatever you most want to
okay this will be a huge threat yeah let
me bring Matthew and him and a friend of
mine a friend of my son actually my
oldest boy he his mother wanted him to
send a thank you note for a party she'd
arranged for his 30th birthday and he he
kept delaying this and eventually he
asked AI to do him a thank you note to
his mum giving it a few details and it
did a note that was so perfect and so
emotional and heart-rending his mother
was reduced to tears when she read it
and said she'd never been so moved by
him no is that is that good or is that
awful I brought great joy to his mother
but she has no idea he was a robot as it
happens on Tuesday my wife sent me an
email she'd gone to gbt and said write a
Sunday Times column in the style of
Matthew science right and I was like
this has got to be terrible I'm reading
through it thank you pretty good I'm
thinking my goodness journalists are
gonna go right and on the question by
the way of we want to connect with the
human how do we know that we're
currently talking to Piers Morgan the
flesh and blood human reality I
completely what would stop you
substituting the Hologram for the I mean
I I think that I interviewed a robot
honestly hey man if you're a robot Good
Morning Britain it was a female robot
and it was it was chilly I mean she
looked like a woman she spoke like a
woman now that was a few years ago God
knows where they're getting to with this
now well they can just be very
convincing humans but with amazingly
high power brains they can be they're
not perfect though yeah I've got a
friend who's a school teacher and she
said that when she gets an essay done by
the robot it's so much better than any
13 year old boy could actually do that
she can really tell which one's which
still at the moment but they'll get
there well they will um I mean finally
Joshua
I've asked a few guesses but what are
you most excited by by the potential of
AI
I think AI as was discussed in the
previous guess is being used for evil
with debt collectors and all of this
stuff but it can also be used for good
and my goal is to give power to the
people and if it makes Ordinary People
the part more powerful than the richest
in society then that's great and so I
think it will level the playing field by
allowing people to
um weaponize AI to help them in their
everyday life all right Jeremy same
question for you quick answer please
yeah I mentioned the huge opportunities
in education I've got a daughter and
where already she's doing stuff with
chat GPT and stuff and it's fantastic
she can learn about anything she wants
to it's an engaging thing you know it's
not replacing teachers at the moment but
I think AI could be used to really
democratize education that's something
I'm very excited about I could actually
see robots taking classes with kids I
mean if they're if they're good enough
and they give them a better personality
why not I mean most teachers do a
version of the same kind of lessons I
mean you get the a few you know a few
who break out and do very different
things each time but they'll do the same
stuff it's gonna be like a personal
tutor for every kid yeah well it's going
to be fascinating um thank you both very
much indeed I appreciate it now once I
said next AI powered deep things to make
politicians and stars repeated doing say
anything I'll say just democracy if we
can't trust our own eyes and ears
foreign
[Music]
fabulous
he sets out this five-point plan what
has it achieved so far nothing when we
say believe women take them at their
word I'm sick of apologies
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
dearly beloved let us Pride they're
careful we're trying to exactly it's
just like some kind of Submarine prime
minister you're making the case here now
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
a MILF stands for mother I'd like to I'm
not going to say the next word did you
keep quiet I'm trying to read a book
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to Piers organizer deep
fakes at AI powered videos which can
make anyone appear to say or do almost
anything they're no longer The Preserve
of nerds or CGI experts freely available
apps can make videos like this in
minutes
hello peers Donald Trump here with a
very special announcement on uh
I'm officially endorsing Ron DeSantis to
be the next president of the United
States God Bless America hey Karen I
mean Piers it's Kanye West here
reminding you that I'm not a shark just
a blowfish and that there's hope for you
too peers have a great show hello Piers
Elon Musk here talking to you from Tesla
headquarters I know you've wanted me on
your show for ages and sorry to
disappoint
it will happen soon I promise maybe on
the moon maybe on Mars but I promise
you'll see me soon
that's actually probably true
um it's just a bit of fun obviously but
it could not be couldn't it you can see
how that could be really quite dangerous
the real potential is obviously
Limitless and that could be a good or
bad thing the power of AI to create and
replicate misinformation obviously poses
enormous threats to democracy British
prime minister which is soon as I said I
AI poses existential risks while Sam
Altman the boss of open a I recently
gave this grave warning to the United
States Congress
for a while people were really quite
fooled by photoshopped images and then
pretty quickly developed an
understanding that images might be
photoshopped this will be like that but
on steroids
so how safe is democracy if we can't
trust our own eyes and ears I'm joined
by the podcaster Kara swisher and the
CEO and co-founder of boson AI Alex
smoler my pack is still with me all
right Cara
um let me start with you because this is
a I don't know whether to be incredibly
thrilled by AI or absolutely terrified
where's your mind with it all
well do you only have two settings Piers
I mean that's the issue is it's not it's
not one or the other I know you have
many many nuanced emotions and that's
unfortunately what's happened here is
the debate is it's going to kill us or
it's going to make us a superhuman and I
don't think it's either thing it's sort
of a lot like the internet and I think
Sam's right that it's on steroids
um but at some point we have to realize
we have control of it and I'm not
particularly scared of AI I'm scared of
people who use Ai and that's really we
have to how we have to think about it
and that it can be regulated it can be
controlled we have we control nuclear uh
proliferation we control all kinds of
things in society and this is just
another one of them but do we don't but
let me do we challenge that but Carl let
me challenge that do we regulate these
things safely I mean at the moment we
have a wall raging in Ukraine or at any
moment Vladimir Putin could unleash a
nuclear weapon no amount of Regulation
is going to stop you he thinks he's
losing that war similarly with AI we can
talk about it being regulated and safe
but the internet has never been properly
regulated why should AI be
well the internet has never been
regulated at least in the Europe it has
but not in the United States so that's
different with nuclear weapons I don't
believe we've been blown up yet uh you
know in all this time and obviously
everyone does have nuclear weapons and
there's more and more people having it
but in general the idea that we can
control it is the one we have to start
with and this is no not different than
that now there's going to be Rogue
players there's going to be threats
there's going to be all kinds of things
but a lot of this is about the people
using it and what's put into it versus
um that it has to go one way or the
other we've seen what happens with lack
of Regulation and that's the current
internet right here again there's
regulations in Europe but not in the
United States
um but you've seen that you can do it
and in this case one thing that's
powerful is it has liability attached to
it and the because of section 230 the
United States it didn't before in this
case AI has liability and so there's
also those issues that can help control
it but it has to be a global effort uh
to decide we're not going to do Killer
Robots we're not going to do this we're
not going to do that
um and and that's where you have to
start uh despite the fact that there
will be Rogue players okay uh Alex Motor
the problem is where there are robots I
can quite envisage your time quite
quickly whether a Killer Robots how do
we stop it
um so there's let me just quickly get
back to one or two things that Kara
brought up before we get to The Killer
Robots
um I think there's a quite significant
difference between uh what you have with
nuclear power and AI
and the big difference is the barrier of
Entry
so it's relatively easy to control a
supply chain of uranium and on top of
that if you handle it and you don't know
what you're doing you're gonna die from
it
and it's only available in certain
locations and all of that
it's very very different by now with AI
tools so once you have a well-trained
model and there is a couple of really
good ones out there for instance metal
released something called llama recently
and this has led to a camera and
explosion of models and by now you can
take a Raspberry Pi that costs less than
fifty dollars and you can make it
generate text
or you can spend about a dollar an hour
on well basically second tier Cloud
providers and you can run much much more
capable models and that has just lowered
the barrier of Entry
to using AI tools rather drastically
this is something that would never be
possible with nuclear power because well
the average human would never have the
resources to actually build a nuclear
reactor in their backyard
but now you can have a teenager buying a
computer for a thousand two thousand
bucks and doing it entirely on his own
or
running it in the cloud for a couple of
dollars
so that's one of the I think key
differentiators
and that
fortunately or unfortunately means that
the genie is really out of the bottle
it's going to be very very difficult
to get people to well pull back on this
just because everybody can do it
but also
um
it creates more opportunity because you
can leads to a very large creative
explosion right okay now on to those
Killer Robots yeah can we quickly on
Killer Robots
yeah so I mean to some extent we have
them already so I guess if you've
watched any videos on in Ukraine if
you've seen a javelin being launched
right so this is one of those okay I'm
probably mischaracterizing it as a
rocket-propelled grenade so it's
basically you know a rocket that's being
launched it flies towards where the tank
is it flies above the tank probably
detects with some sensors okay there's a
tank underneath and then dive bomb
straight from the top into it and
destroys the tank
and we've probably all seen images of
that well there's AI in it the AI in
this case is probably some level of
object detection and then it has a
control mechanism and actuator in it
that will will make this rocket you know
destroy the tank
so in that sense we've had it for
decades
um and I don't think the fear of you
know building a killer robot now is
going to be that much different yes okay
it's easier for instance to track humans
it's easier to also track
um well
pests or animals right and I it's also
easier to track weed this has actually
led to improvements in you know
Precision Agriculture and farming but
obviously if you can track and detect
something you can use it for good and
for evil and with that's well again okay
so again it comes again it comes down to
Faith in human nature I mean Amy you
know the more I hear about this it the
more it comes down really to this well
yeah I mean as long as we can trust
everyone to do the right thing here
we'll be fine but I'm not really that
reassured about this aspect of Bad
actors in this field doing bad stuff
with it I guess it's reassuring that the
you know wish you soon like yesterday
met with a bunch of these Tech CEOs and
I think people like Sam Altman and
demises from deepmind they they they
give the impression that they started
out to try and build something that was
good for Humanity right the amount of
money that he was committing Rishi is
peanuts yeah yeah I mean but you need to
have the CEOs meeting with the
politicians and but then actually
deciding on something I think and the
guard rails where she talked about I
think we need that but Matthew I'm
saying you shaking your head repeatedly
throughout this wouldn't we hear
anything about it's all going to be
regular and so and I kind of agree with
you I don't see why we're being so
trusting about this the genie is out of
the bottle it seems to me potentially a
really bad genie in the wrong hands
right and the analogy with nuclear I
think is absurd it's very difficult to
enrich uranium but almost anybody as a
previous speaker said could
operationalize AI it's all about faith
in human nature I trust a lot of people
but with 8 billion with potential access
to this technology it just requires one
Rogue actor and there's always going to
be one person or one small group of
Fanatics who are going to be driven
either by illness mental illness or a
fanatical ideology who will turn on the
rest of us and I do worry given that
we're being quite philosophical here
most scientists believe that there is
scope in the universe for other
civilizations to emerge what has always
been confusing to them is that we
haven't heard from these other
civilizations and it may just be that
when a civilization
surpasses a technological threshold
where it can destroy itself it becomes
almost impossible to put to use your
phrase the genie back in the bottle
right maybe a really profound filter
that stops US evolving and developing I
agree
um Kara let's send them a positive note
what's the most exciting thing for you
about AI
well you know if you don't like the
nuclear analogy you can think of crispr
you can think there's all kinds of
things that globally should be regulated
together and and have been in the past
and it's again it's not perfect the
things I think are exciting Healthcare
education the two things
um the the stuff they're doing at Google
on protein folding drug Discovery uh
education
um uh all kinds of information in your
hands uh some of the more fun stuff some
around the entertainment could be
interesting
um but largely health care I think that
is really where the real promise is
talking you know your previous guest
talked about is cancer isn't solved
because it can't be solved it's because
it hasn't been solved and I think this
gives us incredible computing power in
our hands so the good news is none of us
will die from cancer in in 30 years the
bad news is we'll all get killed by
killer robots so I guess it's a game of
two halves you'll get killed by people
people will kill us people know the
problem so maybe the robots are right
they don't get rid of us they they
aren't sentient let's just keep that
they're not safe
I interviewed Professor Stephen Hawking
and I asked him what was the biggest in
his last TV interview action I asked him
what was the biggest threat to mankind
he said when artificial intelligence
learns to self-design that's it and
that's exactly what they're all now
warning about he was very early to this
he was yeah
um
I've got to leave it there unfortunately
but thank you very much
sorry you're gone if I may erase
something else that probably would keep
me a lot more awake at night and we'll
see this yeah a lot in the next few
years and that's basically that a lot of
what you would call social media also
use user generated content that a lot of
that will be polluted by generative AI
yeah so for instance if you perform a
Google search for as an AI language
model I cannot
um and you search for that on Amazon
reviews you're going to see a whole lot
of reviews not bad reviews but very
clearly synthetically generated ones
um polluting by now that review database
I mean as long as they pollute it so
that when my next book comes out they're
all glowing reviews I'm kind of I'm not
against that I've got to leave it there
but thank you very much indeed Alex I'd
love to talk more we're running out of
time Cara thank you very much indeed I
know you've had a busy day so I
appreciate you taking time for us as
well thank you stay with me uh talk
about job
one says the next AI can write jokes he
can make music and create award-winning
art in seconds so what's the point of
creative people anymore William Shatner
and Howie Mandel will debate that next
thank you
thank you very much
it sure is an honor to be here but you
are on America's Got Time
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage
you can say whatever gender you are of
your sex your male or your female all
right JJ plus he becomes fabulous
but Rishi sunai sets out this five-point
plan what has it achieved so far nothing
when we say believe women take them at
their word I'm sick of apology
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
really beloved that's a Sprite they're
careful who are you praying too exactly
it's just like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now pop the kettle on this is the
royal tea a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word did you keep quiet I'm trying to
read the book
[Music]
welcome back AI systems can make music
generate art mimic photography and write
somehow you could augment human
Ingenuity enabling artists to explore
novel Avenues and collaborate with AI in
innovative ways but it could clearly
impact cultural jobs others fear risks
the total loss of human creativity and
in bad news for TV writers everything I
just said was scripted by AI but is also
being used in the entertainment industry
to bring beloved singers and movie
characters back to life America's Got
Talent the show I used to work and also
got a taste of just what AI can do when
Simon Cowell Harry Mandel and Terry
Crews stood in the stage or at least
their AI replicas did
[Music]
[Applause]
well I'm now joined by the comedian star
of NBC's America's Got Talent Howie
Mandel and legendary actor William
Shatner welcome to both of you so Howie
um I mean I knew it was a fake the
moment I heard you sing because you
can't sing so uh but was it a weird
experience seeing that and what do you
think of AI where's your mind with all
this
amazing I am so up on technology I love
it I think we got to embrace it I I've
been listening to your show from the
beginning uh people uh screaming fire in
the building I I think number one nobody
and there is no uh choice in stopping it
there's no way you're going to stop it
Embrace technology I always have I I
embrace AI I embrace Holograms I've
invested in a hologram company which is
actually in the O2 right there
proto-hologram and that's because I can
be in two places at once I would love to
somebody to write for me I would like to
I've actually licensed my AI image to a
Korean company because I want to be able
to be places and do things without being
there it makes me much more productive
it makes the world productive you know
nobody stopped the automobile even
though all the blacksmiths seem to have
lost their job you know we'll just find
new things to do okay but how would you
feel how would you feel artistically if
if an AI robot was able to write all
your jokes for you and you literally had
no input would you care
as long as you pay me but the truth is
what you're saying doesn't really exist
you know we need the human annuity or
creativity to prompt AI we need to come
up with the ideas of what we want AI to
do you're not going to stop this
technology we didn't stop the world wide
web and you know people are putting
things out there and we could generate I
don't know if you're on Instagram but a
lot of people are a lot better looking
than they actually are it enhances yes
there are naysayers that uh that say bad
things will happen but bad things happen
with cars bad things happen with all
technology bad things happen just when
people are left to their own this is all
good people you know what if bad things
used to happen AI a golden buzzer yeah I
mean bad things used to happen to me
when I work with you quite regularly
normally because of you
um let me go to William shat I miss you
buddy look at the William Shatner
William you celebrated your 90th
birthday recently by creating an AI
powered version of yourself that will
live forever which I was thrilled to
hear about but does that mean you're all
over this too the AI phenomenon are you
embracing it with great Glee or you
worried I I too have been listening to
your program from the beginning of what
I'm missing and what I think
is uh possibly promising is morality how
do you teach a computer morality which
brings us back to human beings how do
you teach morality to human beings will
it be possible to teach these artificial
intelligence entities as they become
more and more sophisticated morality and
so they cannot be able to do bad things
to harm people
uh then you get into the question of
authentication can you authenticate an
image so that there's no question that
it's an imitation or it's the real thing
you're there are areas that are
sophisticated that can help uh take care
of the things that we've heard on this
program that are very real taking will a
uh will a uh uh a a uh artificial
intelligence become sentient yeah will
it feel endorphins and and will it feel
good when it does something good and
feel bad when it does something bad if
it could be taught to do that I mean the
thing is most of the areas the thing is
with him I mean you can teach look you
can teach a dog you can teach a child
you can teach them to about morality and
they'll pick it up and learn it the
thing about AI presumably you ask about
morality if you feed enough information
into AI about morality and what is moral
and what is right and what is wrong why
wouldn't it be even better than any
child assimilating that information
that's exactly what I'm saying that's
exactly what I'm saying built internally
into every AI is a morality but then how
do you teach morality because morality
differs from and how do you stop it how
do you stop it conversely how do you
stop it being immoral how do you stop a
nefarious actor getting hold of it
exactly Insanity from doing that
say that again Harry well you can't stop
how do you stop Humanity but that's
right so that's why when you get all
over excited about it and say how
brilliant this all is I am genuinely
worried simply because history tells us
that yes every great new innovation is
great but in the hands of Bad actors
this is including the internet for
example bad things can happen and I'm
not sure welcome to the world disappears
this is I've talked about my own
I got
well
everybody thought it was a bad thing the
first time I purchased an inflatable sex
doll but now my wife has so much more
time to watch her TV show
okay William on the bad stuff I mean I
totally agree with you if you can turn
AI moral great if it can be turned
equally easily to be immoral what do we
do about that
our artificial intelligence is merely an
extension at the moment of humanity and
Humanity carries with it uh the great
goodness of the web telescope and the uh
horror of the Ukraine war we carry that
capacity within us the our machines that
help us will have the same capacity how
do we regulate that how do we
authenticate that those are problems
that need to be solved and are soluble
but we can't ignore them what is for you
Howie the most exciting thing about AI
what are you most looking forward to
being able to do with it
productivity to be in more than one
place and do more than one thing more
than I as a human have the capacity to
do you know and um I've invested in
companies like protohologram and AI
companies to be to be bigger and more
productive than I actually am yeah and
you know listen what we have in the
capacity that I have as a human being is
finite is short is is is in a box and
now I can think outside that box and I
can be in multiple locations at once and
it may not even be me and I'm okay with
that as long as I get some credit for
whatever was created and William very
quickly for you the most exciting idea
about AI that you've had
I just read this morning AI is starting
to invent a antibiotic that uh is will
take care of the superbugs that's just
the beginning of the steps that AI can
help us with
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage
you can say whatever gender you are but
your sex your male or your female all
right JJ of course he becomes fabulous
but Rishi sooner who sets out this
five-point plan what has it achieved so
far nothing when we say believe women
take them at their word I'm sick of
apologies
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it